bonsoir en ia lowe's merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sur rt france tout
d'abord votre réaction à cette annonce
[Musique]
c'est prévisible
la presse a décidé de prendre avance sur
leurs résultats officiels dans cette
élection a et c'est compréhensible que
les électeurs des bas de soie coton et
qui descendent dans la rue c'est c'est
aussi une façon de voir la victoire pour
eux a scellé par tennis c'est une étape
on est devant les tribunaux il y a des
preuves assez forte parce qu'on a pu
obtenir on a des différentes
attestations et des témoins qui ont
clairement établi
même mot dans l'état du michigan i need
is qui a déjà nous un homme du dih
commission des élections indiqué la
fraude a été instauré chez eux à
michigan et on a des témoins partout
dans différents états qui l'établît ciel
des justes nous du ciel qui avaient des
bugs qui osent est utilisé dans
plusieurs dizaines d'états qui ont
transféré des voix à monsieur barry dont
le travail sera fait et moi j'attends de
travail des avocats des juges de
l'enquêté relève biya et la police pour
mettre la lumière à tous ces affaires by
lm pour le moment est content j'imagine
les démocrates sont contentes
on attendra les 8 décembre pour
l'addition finale et officielle qui est
devant nous voilà je pense que ça on a
une longue bataille judiciaire d'un mois
devant nous alors on va justement
écoutez à ce sujet vous restez avec nous
on dit elle aux rudolph giuliani
l'un des avocats de donald trump qui
s'est exprimé juste après l annonce de
ce les résultats regard des scandales
pour un enjeu aussi énorme
avec cette méthode de vote aussi
suspecte il n'y a aucune certitude 0 les
gens de cette ville les gens de ce pays
n'ont aucune assurance que ces votes ont
vraiment été enregistré ils ont presque
exclusivement été compté par des gens
qui souhaitaient que joe biden rattrape
son retard je vous parle de ce qui se
passe à philadelphie mais nous devons
alerter les gens de pittsburgh que la
même fraude qu'ici a été commise et
aussi la même chose s'est passé en
géorgie la même chose a été faite au
michigan
la même chose a été faite en caroline du
nord à moi il me semble que quelqu'un du
comité national démocrate a dû envoyer
une petite note disant ne laissez pas
les républicains regarder de plus près
ces millions de votes
donc arrête de leur propre keynes drop
atos meriem barotte un randy aloses on
n'a pas de nouvelles de donald trump
théoriquement il aurait dû appeler jo
weiden comme celle usage pour le
féliciter or là visiblement il n'a pas
l'intention de le faire il est parti
jouer au golf vous savez je félicite et
je pense que c'est mal venus séjourner
question madame excusez-moi j'ai entendu
ce qui est là vous savez ce qu'ils ont
trouvé dans les témoignages des
personnes qui ont été entendues
ils ont dit qu'ils avaient tout ce qui
n'est pas des officiels dont les parts
des démocratique il faut pas laisser les
observateurs républicains
regardez les bulletins de vote ce style
kia est notée inquiété à circuler donc
vous comprenez bien les côtés les
combats républicains à des réticences
par rapport à ça et une contestation
très sérieuse par rapport à la
régularité des élections dont
aujourd'hui on attend et ils ont les
médias étaient toujours en titre up aux
états unis fox a changé de chemise à la
dernière minute parce que ils sont
peut-être peut-être qu'ils ne vont pas
changer mes
tout n'est pas joué et il faut il faut
laisser le temps au temps
il faut pas vendre la peau de l'ours
avant de la battre il faut prendre son
temps pour le faire le président a dit
qu'il avait peut-être l'intention de
contester ce que c'est une certitude que
ça ira devant les tribunaux selon vous
c'est déjà devant les tribunaux il ya
plusieurs actions qui ont été menées
on a des témoins qui entraîne d'être
entendu par les autorités il n'y a plus
que six roquettes par les gars vous
savez si une enquête est intenté par les
vias et déjà il ya un commence notre
preuve donc etc il ya des allégations
sur la question aujourd'hui c'est quelle
est l'étendue de la fraude
aujourd'hui c'est ils vont se trouvent
ils vont trouver certainement des
irrégularités aujourd'hui fondue
déterminer l'étendue et les faits sur le
nombre des bulletins qui auraient été
affectées par ces comportements
frauduleux et c'est ça aujourd'hui
il faut pouvoir aller jusqu'au bout de
cette enquête
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas connaître les
différentes possibilités comme il a dix
minutes julian ici au michigan et à
pittsburgh à philadelphie en caroline du
nord
on a un problème celui-ci particulier
dont plusieurs étapes
donc on verra bien et il faut laisser la
justice faire son travail
il faut laisser les billets et les la
police enquêter et on aura des résultats
et les problèmes aujourd'hui surtout ça
décrédibilise la l'intégrité du système
électoral parce que si demain on a des
problèmes à travers les états unis et
qui retrouve qu'il ya au fait et qui a
une faute s'il ya des différences
personnes au sein du camp démocrate qui
ont participé à des fraudes
vous pouvez imaginer même si après les
élections sont pour by d'imaginer ce
n'est pas aussi étendue message dans
certains états est ce que vous pensez y
aura pas un atteinte importante à
l'intégrité du système électoral ça va
être très grave et aujourd'hui
malheureusement les preuves vont dans ce
sens et j'espère avoir tort parce que en
fin de compte que ce soit bail d'une
autre trempe ce qui sera pire ce sera
là la défiance et la perte de confiance
des américains vis-à-vis du système
électoral et des ceux qui les
représentent qui sont prêts à l'est
jusqu'à la tricherie et j'espère qu'on
n'est pas dans la situation et j'espère
vraiment sincèrement là là on voit
évidemment on dirait que les images de
washington une ville qui est plutôt
démocrate a priori il y à d'autres
villes aux états unis où effectivement
les électeurs qui ont voté donald trump
ne reconnaissent pas ils disent que ce
sont des résultats annoncés par les
médias américains
quel est l'état d'esprit de l'autre
moitié de l'amérique que l'on ne voit
pas forcément randy gallows aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui ils sont très très déçu et
pour eux c'est il comprend pas comment
dans une heure course si serré quand il
ya du multi problème des et des
allégations des fraudes et je ne dis pas
ça ça avec légèreté
je dois vous rappeler qu' hier les
directeurs de la commission des
élections fédérales c'est celle à
l'autorité fédérale qui s'occupent et
surprise les élections a dit qu'ils
avaient des allégations de fraude qui
apparaissent fondées donc quand vous
êtes dans cette situation
est ce que vous pensez pas qu'il est
prématuré de se déclarer président et de
ses dires c'est légitime
avant que les résultats soient certifiés
et officielle par les différents états
on n'est pas dans cette situation
aujourd'hui est ce que on avait dit
craindre quelques violences et quelques
tensions à la proclamation des des
premiers résultats auront le voit pour
l'instant ce n'est pas le cas est-ce que
ça reste un des hypothèses a ajouté
aujourd'hui ce qu'on voit c'est je vends
quais et dans vos images ce que j'ai vu
à la télé parce que moi je venais
confiné en lait de noix on voit les
différents rue des états unis avec des
tous les supporter des bagnes qui
descendent dans la rue c'est eux qui
sont contents et aujourd'hui je pense
que les américains surtout ceux qui ont
voté pour trompent ils sont peu sûres et
choc de voir deux amériques
deux perceptions et 1 milliard qui n'a
aucun pouvoir politique et
institutionnelle déclarant en vainqueur
alors qu'ils font partie d aucune
institution ne vous imaginez si c'est
vous qui vous déclaré le président de la
france vous imaginez c'est les médias
qui sont 32 des cas qui est le président
des états unis et et les gens sont en
train de descendre la rue dans la rue et
le président de la france en train de
féliciter un président parce que les la
presse les le déclare vainqueur alors
qu'il ya encore des soucis et des
allégations de fortes qui existent on
devrait au moins attendre même la fin
des résultats aujourd'hui encore il ya
plusieurs états et on peut avoir des
différents résultats des différentes à
résultats par rapport à apple ce béni et
on en importe que plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de voix je pense qu'il n'est
qu'un 98%
il est encore deux pour cent des
bulletins de vote qui n'ont pas été
cotées c'est il ya un manque de
discrétion un manque de transparence je
dois rappeler dans cette émission aussi
vous savez mais se trompe en 2016 suite
aux élections de 2016 a essayé d établir
une commission sur la fraude électorale
et les les quinze états démocrate
à cette époque en 2017 ont refusé de
partager des informations sur les
modalités et des élections et les
défenses informations n'ont pas été
partagée avec cette commission en 2017
qui il pouvait pas conclure ou non
comment il était comment ça fonctionne
et comment améliorer l et réduire le
risque d des fraudes y compris c'était
pour la californie y compris les peines
venez donc nous avons des problèmes de
transparence au niveau de chaque état on
a un problème au niveau du système
électoral de certains états qui ont
elles encore on a une commission pour
essayer d'être transparent le travail
des chaque état certes ces tares et en
dons de ce cas particulier dont en 2017
on refusait donc comment voulez vous que
des américains qui ont voté pour 30
puisse avoir confiance dans l'intégrité
du système électoral alors que
aujourd'hui on n'attend même pas les
résultats 2 il ya vraiment des problèmes
importants qui ont été démontrées a
priori on a des témoins
il ya une circulation et ja il en allait
il ya des accusations et jusqu'à ou que
ça plaît et semblerait qu est comme on
avait dit qu'il ya une personne qui est
dit faudra pas partagé à les bulletins
doivent ou pas les montrer aux examens
des républicains et si ça s'avère vrai
et à travers plus de l'état
même si demain ça reste pas d entre vous
et moi qui ai même s'il devient
vainqueur officiellement ça va faire un
dégât important pour la confiance des
américains et surtout ceux qui ont voté
pour trappe et qui demain ils vont dire
que on peut pas faire confiance à une
partie des institutions au niveau des
états parce que il n'ya pas de
transparence et ils auront ont peut-être
raison
certes mais n'ont rien donné pas plus
faire confiance je dire je peux
comprendre cette frustration
moi je m'exprime pour eux merci beaucoup
ont dit elle aux effectivement on va
suivre cela sur notre antenne merci en
tout cas réagi en direct à cette annonce
des médias américains de la victoire de
joe biden des actuels